leadership can grab I think you know
what's funny I think this is like the
cliche Wednesday after Labor Day right
like today it's [ __ ] real
[Music]
just got out of babbitt about some of
the footage yeah just got out of the
leadership eating bunch of times
you gotta the leadership need a bunch of
the leaders got a lot done grounded
super excited about kind of getting the
fourth quarter underway everybody kind
of updating the rest of the leadership
team on where they're going how they're
going about it and okay I've been
texting about this yes there's a ton to
drop off after thirty seconds yes
there's a ton of chopped up thirty
seconds based on videos that are longer
than 30 seconds there's a lot of
fascinating little games being played in
the digital world I don't know
Facebook's doing this the video was 33
seconds and the drop up having a 30
seconds do you know what it means I
almost feel like I want to write this
deck you know how I do it hey I know
I've gotten everybody in love with
long-form and that is been some of our
special source sauce but that's not in
lieu of short and there's a lot of data
supporting short is that right great
news we just [ __ ] filmed it yeah
Bainer media I'm being dead serious
vaynermedia
I'm sending you a deck right now this is
the attached video a few moments later
have an awesome day
so series of productive meetings off the
bat what's the early theme of the day
leadership can grant I think you know
it's funny I think this is like the
cliche Wednesday after Labor Day right
like today it's [ __ ] real you know
seems like today there's a lot of
[ __ ] people around like you got it
got real real fast for here in Long
Island City and the new vaynermedia
office and Studio 50,000 square feet of
video and audio producing and running
accounts Adams
I'm gonna go work hey guys doing good
hey amazing I've done this exact talk on
the road in these places
now we're gonna so what I'm gonna say it
and my city indirectly - I've been to
Foxborough
[Music]
I just came out of makeup they told me I
was beautiful but not beautiful enough
but now I'm ready
looks like they're filming me I'm the
actual talent in the shot so this is
unusual it's the first time I'm excited
about it
it's triple meta we've got you babban
here I own boehner productions up in one
day and wear it backwards my friends
super excited so far there's my
production team happen
there's the Vayner productions team
really enjoying working with them
excited about where vena Productions is
going working with clients work on a
bunch of you guys you new film work
we're the gang we're two fellows or two
gals
yeah we need to take a a me sitting
we're gonna make a display cardboard
display and they're gonna build it
inside of inside of wine library and run
it the video on TVs do an event again
that sounds true Tyler just got fired
guys freaking new stylish MIT fired hmm
before trying to sell liquor to his
family's Montclair store which I respect
which I respect the movie picked up for
me only to be your own demise listen it
was fun to have him around
remember Tyler Schmidt he was a good you
hired me he just got fired but it was
really great he had a great run get a
great run I'm fired
how are you good some real pleasure how
you doing yeah thanks for doing this no
problem I'm happy to connect yeah you
well yeah I'm happy my cousin sent it to
me yeah yeah Jersey City oh yeah I love
it I grew up in Edison oh yeah I did a
little research yeah actually no Verity
before I appreciate it yeah yeah
let us know let us know if there's
anything we can do enjoy a few very real
pleasure thank you yeah it's super
important for you leave the part where
he says I didn't know who you were you
guys need to know that 99% still don't
do know exactly who I am that's exactly
the best part of this whole [ __ ]
thing all of you worry about like making
it and this and that never [ __ ] make
it this is a [ __ ] struggle forever
you never make it you're always grinding
bye guys take care we should do a meetup
right in here YouTube what do you guys
think meetup right in here Sean Babbitt
we're gonna drop it somewhere in the
winter we're gonna do meetup here like a
late night just do a [ __ ] party we
can arrest it we want to use it as a
prospecting event or the advisory board
right does it have to park you are
[Music]
are you I need all the content support I
need an Instagram story I need a
Facebook campaign okay
just had an interview with Nicky clouds
been here for a while
subdued runs our Chattanooga office I'm
a fan just a strategic talk about the
office the offerings the opportunities
the the good the bad the ugly also met
with Kim Garcia from Bainer experience
our events business is exploding four DS
that a lot of you guys know about kind
of wine event we're gonna be doing some
other events that we're rolling with so
just a lot of good [ __ ] going on now
meeting with it old friend cool fun day
what was really a fun part of days I was
doing some content for a client to
multiple takes I have to take when I'm
not in control of the Burbidge made me
laugh all those different takes
I don't know how baboons gonna edit it
was it was super funny but really just
enjoying the action of the city right
now headed to the US open with a client
be fun to get a little tennis action in
see one of the all-time greats to his
thing Roger Federer have a lot of
respect for him even know I'm a joker
fan and just really glad to be back on
the grind and and back with you guys
really uh just miss you guys a lot now
headed to uh catch downtown in New York
City to hang out with one of my
favorites you'll see Oney her Oney him
distribution absolutely period yeah 1-0
day reality everything we [ __ ] think
about comes true so don't [ __ ]
careful don't care about who you affect
if you offend me i'ma think about your
demise
[Music]
[Applause]